buongiorno a tutti io mi chiamo giovanni
perrone insomma
docente all'università di palermo e ho
accettato questo invito perché il tema
di questa conferenza conseguenze
impreviste è un tema che ha molto
caratterizzato la mia vita direi per tre
motivi il primo motivo è perché per il
mio lavoro io faccio un lavoro che credo
che sia meraviglioso almeno per me lo è
faccio il professore universitario ed è
una cosa meravigliosa perché ho a che
fare con lo studio con la ricerca con
nuovi argomenti con la possibilità di
confrontarmi
ma soprattutto perché ho a che fare con
la risorsa che credo sia la più preziosa
di ogni società i giovani ei giovani
sono fonte di conseguenze impreviste
perché sono fonte di creatività sono
fonte di nuove tematiche di confronto di
creatività di tante cose che causano
conseguenze impreviste
la seconda ragione per cui ho a che fare
col tema delle conseguenze impreviste è
il mio tema di ricerca io mi occupo di
innovazione
mi occupo di management dell'innovazione
di gestione dell'innovazione e cosa c'è
di più imprevisto dell'innovazione
soprattutto quando l'innovazione come
diciamo noi è distruttiva cioè quando
l'innovazione cambia il nostro modo di
vivere
se pensate negli ultimi anni come per
esempio le tecnologie dell'informazione
e della comunicazione hanno cambiato in
pochi anni in pochi decenni il vostro
modo di vivere pensate a quante
conseguenze impreviste
l'innesto di queste tecnologie
ha determinato nelle vostre vite bene io
mi occupo appunto di innovazione
tecnologica come attività di ricerca è
questa attività a che fare con le
conseguenze impreviste
il terzo motivo per cui la tematica
delle conseguenze impreviste mi
interessa e quindi sono qui e che circa
dieci anni fa allora rettore
dell'università di palermo mi ha chiesto
dato che mi occupavo di innovazione
ricominciar mi ad occupare di una delle
attività che la nostra università
università di palermo cominciato appunto
circa dieci anni fa è questa attività
era quella delle start up cioè della
creatività imprenditoriale che venisse
dalla ricerca scientifica e tecnologica
ma anche umanistica che si fa
all'interno di università generalistica
come l'università di palermo quindi
circa 10 dieci anni fa ho cominciato ad
occuparmi di start up sono entrato nel
board dell'incubatore di palermo
dell'università di palermo che si chiama
arca e soprattutto ho cominciato ad
occuparmi della start cup competition
cioè della competizione per nuove idee
di impresa che si chiama start cup
palermo che allora quando l'ho presa in
mano ogni anno mobilitava circa una
decina di innovative all'anno 10 15
dell'innovativo all'anno e oggi ogni
anno a questa competizione partecipano
circa 40 50 idee innovative che vengono
il nostro tessuto dal nostro eco sistema
dell'università di palermo e di tutto
ciò che è collegato
questa esperienza mi ha consentito di
crescere moltissimo perché dopo circa
sette anni che coordinava la startup la
start cup palermo sono diventato
presidente nazionale dell'associazione
nazionale degli incubatori universitari
e quindi oggi mi occupo di tutto ciò che
il sistema universitario fa nell'ambito
del cosiddetto ecosistema
dell'innovazione
quindi il tema delle start up è un altro
tema che ha a che fare con le
conseguenze impreviste le start up sono
fonte di innovazione sono il mezzo
attraverso cui l'innovazione arriva al
mercato e sono se pensate diciamo a
forse siamo tutte le più importanti
aziende hi tech che voi conoscete sono
cito google facebook per cento citarne
qualcuna tutte sono state tutte delle
startup quindi i tre elementi che oggi
mi piacerebbe mettere insieme sono
proprio questi l'elemento il tema dei
giovani
il tema dell'innovazione e il tema delle
start up
allora vorrei cominciare diciamo dando
una definizione di start up innovativa
una startup innovativa è una impresa
creativa nuova innovativa che porta
innovazione nel mercato c'è anche
ovviamente una definizione che viene dal
decreto che è stato approvato qualche
anno fa sulle start up innovative
però a me quello che piace dire per una
start up innovative che una start up che
cammina nelle gambe di giovani
imprenditori per me gli imprenditori
sono tutti i giovani anche se hanno 60
anni
di giovani imprenditori e che portano
idee innovative nel mercato dove
innovazione significa una cosa
innovazione significa creatività
economica creatività economica perché se
non c'è l'elemento della creatività
non possiamo parlare di innovazione se
non c'è l'elemento dell'economicità cioè
che con l'innovazione bisogna fare
mercato
non possiamo parlare di un'attività
imprenditoriale di successo allora
l'elemento che vorrei discutere
brevemente con voi e questo perché le
start up innovative
oggi sono diventate così importanti per
l'economia di un paese penso diciamo che
tutti voi ne abbiate sentito parlare è
il nostro paese ha assunto una
legislazione
diciamo favorevole sulle start up
innovative però qual è la ragione per
cui le start up innovative sono
diventate oggi così importanti per la
crescita economica di un paese perché è
cambiato e torniamo al tema
dell'innovazione il paradigma con cui si
innova oggi non si innova più attraverso
una innovazione interna alle imprese ma
si innova sempre di più attraverso una
cosiddetta innovazione aperta
cosa significa di pazzino aperta
significa che le imprese cercano
innovazione laddove nel mercato questa
innovazione è disponibile e quando
trovano il tipo di innovazione che
interessa loro approcciano questa
innovazione contante
diciamo metodologie per esempio con
l'acquisto delle startup oppure
attraverso delle alleanze o attraverso
l'acquisto dei talenti eccetera eccetera
e dico fanno propria questa innovazione
è la inseriscono diciamo nel proprio
sistema produttivo oppure l'altro caso
che per esempio il caso di google è di
facebook che ho citato poco fa è una
start up innovativa riesce a trovare un
ecosistema favorevole oltre che idee
ovviamente eccezionali persone
eccezionali perché le start up camminano
sulle gambe degli imprenditori
quindi bisogna avere delle persone
eccezionali e riescono a diventare delle
grandi imprese come appunto google e
facebook che tutti conosciamo e che
adesso sono dei player fondamentali nel
mercato dell'innovazione tecnologica
quindi il cambiamento del paradigma
dell'innovazione cioè da innovazione
chiusa donazione che viene dall'interno
delle imprese ad innovazione aperta ha
spostato la focalizzazione sugli
elementi e quindi su elementi come le
start up che siano in grado di generare
nuova innovazione di portarla sul
mercato e metterla a disposizione di
coloro a cui questa innovazione
serve quindi sostanzialmente il
paradigma nell'innovazione aperta
spezzato la valigia in quindi la catena
del valore dell'innovazione e diciamo
l'ha resa un po come diciamo una catena
del valore di un supermercato in cui c'è
il supermercato che vi vende le cose
qualcuno che produce tanto è vero che
oggi si dice che la conoscenza è quasi
una commodity
questo elemento è fondamentale e questo
elemento è importante perché pone
l'accento fortemente sul primo aspetto
che io
di cui ho discusso i giovani il giovane
utente io mi riferisco ai giovani che
sono i nostri studenti universitari cioè
di coloro che hanno deciso di voler
frequentare un'università di voler fare
degli studi e di voler acquisire delle
conoscenze diciamo che vengono
attraverso degli studi universitari
perché perché in un ecosistema in cui
l'innovazione è portata fuori
diciamo dalle recenti delle università
attraverso delle iniziative che sono
appunto che salta per i giovani studenti
hanno un ruolo fondamentale ed è questo
su cui occorre lavorare occorre lavorare
a che il bagaglio di conoscenze e di
competenze che si è acquisito
all'interno dell'università
specialmente a chi fa diciamo un
percorso universitario completo quindi
arrivato una laurea magistrale o
addirittura un dottorato di ricerca bene
che questo bagaglio culturale possa
essere in qualche modo finalizzato ad
un'esperienza di imprenditoriale di
innovazione di creazione di una start up
perché dico di dico possa essere perché
sappiamo benissimo che fondare una
startup e avere successo con una start
up è cosa difficilissima difficilissima
perché nel tunnel e dell'innovazione un
imbuto terribile quindi solamente alcuni
hanno successo però quello che io posso
dirvi dalla mia dal mio osservatorio è
che tutti coloro qui sto parlando
appunto gli studenti considerate che
come mondo dell'accademia italiano noi
attraverso
le start cup competition che ci sono in
giro per l'italia non lo facciamo in 15
regioni e attraverso un evento che si
chiama premio nazionale innovazione che
tra l'altro sarà la settimana prossima a
verona quest'anno che è una sorte di
coppa dei campioni tutte le start up
universitarie noi attraverso questa rete
ogni anno dalle università
proponiamo circa duemila giovani
imprenditori di mila imprenditori circa
mille idee imprenditoriali circa 500
business plan
quindi mi splende un documento diciamo
che potremmo chiamarle documento
progettuale di una start up e circa 100
nuove startup quindi duemila persone che
si cimentano ogni anno in una iniziativa
in una nuova iniziativa imprenditoriale
di queste 2 mila persone circa il 28 per
cento sono studenti il 28 per cento sono
studenti bene non tutte queste start up
come vi ho detto hanno successo però
quello che succede
direi nel 90 per cento dei casi e che
gli studenti che partecipano a queste
iniziative sono studenti che poi nella
vita hanno successo non nella startup ma
in quello che andranno a fare perché
vedete cimentarsi in una esperienza di
questo tipo e mobilità un po coeli quei
soft skill noi li chiamiamo che ho
sentito anche da qualche intervento
precedente che sono necessari che sono
importanti per sviluppare un percorso
professionale di carriera di successo la
capacità di mettersi in gioco la
capacità di relazionarsi con altre
persone
la capacità di affrontare rischi la
capacità di prendere bastonate e
il giorno dopo continuare in quella
direzione
con le proprie convinzioni
la capacità di essere creativi queste
cose sono delle delle attitudini delle
capacità che sono necessarie per chi
vuole per un qualunque studente che
vuole intraprendere nella sua carriera
professionale
una carriera di crescita e sono delle
attitudini che qualunque chiunque
qualunque datore di lavoro troverete
almeno che non si trova non avrete un
datore di lavoro diciamo del giovedì e
del millennio scorso sarà sono delle
attitudini e qualunque datore di lavoro
apprezzerà e valorizzerà quindi per me è
quello che io suggerisco è sempre quello
di cercare se uno ovviamente ne ha la
possibilità alla voglia perché
ovviamente queste cose si fanno
solamente diciamo se c'è la passione se
c'è diciamo la volontà di farlo di
accoppiare al proprio percorso di studi
un'esperienza di questo tipo anche che
sia un'esperienza diciamo ridotta che
sia l'esperienza semplicemente di aver
così di avere diciamo sottomesso un'idea
imprenditoriale a qualcuno di aver
lavorato ad un business plan di essere
entrati in un team di giovani
imprenditori è un'esperienza che pagate
un'esperienza che paga veramente nella
vostra crescita nella crescita dei degli
studenti della crescita dei giovani e
che poi vi ritroverete diciamo come
bagaglio futuro
quindi concludendo vorrei dire giovani
innovazione start up è un modo per
realizzare
diciamo un connubio di conseguenze
impreviste chiamiamole così che possono
avere valore sia a livello individuale
quindi a livello della
vita personale e professionale di una
persona sia a livello sociale perché è
dunque non una classe dirigente che una
classe dirigente diversa una classe
dirigente che non sa focalizzazione su
il posto fisso ma focalizzazione sulla
creatività focalizzazione sul sulla
capacità di assumere rischi sulla voglia
di diciamo creare qualcosa è un impatto
sull'economia del nostro paese che è
un'economia che ha bisogno sempre di più
di innovazione e diciamo di incrementare
quando possibile la competitività
attraverso appunto l'innovazione grazie
[Applauso]